Speaker 1: All right, let's get into this
week's mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
If you have something to say, please don't
abuse the email.
Unfortunately, the more the reason I keep
saying this is we now have over 100 different
people that are emailing us so regularly,
almost using our email address like a blog,
free, free association of whatever is going
through their minds.
We have over 100 people whose emails are automatically
filtered into a folder that we never look
at unless law enforcement says, please forward
us your communications with these people,
which sometimes happens, but please don't
abuse it.
OK, let's let's keep it.
Let's keep it respectful.
All right, let's jump right into it here.
Here's someone who sounds reasonable.
Why aren't you talking about the Biden crime
family dragging us into war?
The Burisma deal with Hunter Biden is going
to have the say in war with Russia.
And because Biden colluded with Russia, gave
them the pipeline, we have no bargaining and
we're over a barrel, this will not be a just
war, but an evil war.
Of course you won't because you're nothing
but a communist propagandist, a liar lying
your damn ass off.
Brutal attack.
Brutal attack on the English language here.
I actually think that it's legally a requirement
that if you write hate mail, you have to use
the wrong your versus your like you apostrophe
it.
It seems to be a legal requirement from what
I'm getting.
If we end up in a conflict with Russia, it
will not be the United States alone, and it
will not be because of Hunter Biden.
I don't know that there's that much else to
say here.
And so I won't say anything else.
Next message only commie idiots like you think
Democrats are actually good in one line.
You can pack such disinformation and this
one is funny because I'm neither a communist
nor a Democrat.
And as those who have been following the show
for some time, no, I get criticized by the
actual socialists because I'm not a socialist.
And then the right says I am a socialist or
in this case, a communist in terms of Democrats
are good.
I think I'm one of the most consistently indifferent
to the Democratic Party.
I'm not as actively hostile to it as others
are, but I don't care at all about the Democratic
Party.
I've never been a Democrat.
I see the Democratic Party as having as its
number one goal self-preservation.
They want to stay in power.
And I really couldn't care less about the
Democratic Party as far as Democrats are good.
If you're talking about how I vote.
I look at each race, I look at the candidates
and I pick the one that I think would do the
least damage and the most good.
It's it's almost boring.
But no, not a communist, not a Democrat, either.
Michael wrote in about religious exemptions.
Michael says, Hey David, I just watched your
segment about the serviceman who was asking
for the religious exemption for the vaccine.
He said something about the pedigree of technology
or something and then ended with convicted
in the spirit.
Then you rightly pointed out all the other
vaccines that service members are required
to get, and asked where in the Bible or other
religious text does it say one list is fine,
but the COVID vaccine is bad?
Mike writes the only thing he said that he
could argue to those who speak his language.
Going back to Amanda Man cult language concepts
is convicted in the spirit.
As a recent convert away from Christianity,
I still recognize the coded language of the
group.
This means, in short, God is telling him not
to get the vaccine, and that is his justification
for religious exemption, not any text.
Any rational person wouldn't be able to follow
his logic.
But most in Christendom would.
That's very interesting.
So it's sort of like a get out of jail free
card.
If you say, well, my religion, I'm against
it for religious reasons and then someone
like me shows up and I understand I got a
very nice email from a lawyer who said, legally,
it's problematic to say, Show us where your
religion says that I get it.
But someone like me shows up in a conversation
and I go, Oh, where does your religion say
that?
It seems that this I'm convicted by the spirit
not to get the vaccine is sort of like a get
out of jail free catchall where you can drop
that in and it could basically just be God
told me.
God told me not to get it, and of course,
that puts us in the realm of India feasible.
Well, I don't know whether whatever this person
thinks, God told them, we can't really prove
or disprove one way or the other.
Many of you writing in about the recent word
salads from Jordan Peterson and one such person
was Kim.
Kim wrote in and said, Hey David.
Regarding Jordan Peterson's incoherent biblical
rant, I believe it was his attempt to explain
that the Bible, as we know it today, is a
collection of books.
For example, the Book of Matthew is a book
that's included in the Bible.
I think you were right when you said that
his word salad tricks people into thinking
he's smarter than they are.
Peterson says enough logical, well-thought
out comments to bait his audience.
This interview is obviously not well thought
out and referring to clips of him from years
ago.
But once he hooks his listeners, he leads
them down the incel pipeline that creates
school shooters.
That's very, very aggressive.
And I suspect.
Not completely without merit.
But, yeah, the the the tough thing about Jordan
Peterson is he always did the word salads
and they were always very borderline in terms
of being sort of interesting and being wacky,
disjointed delusions.
And I think it's it's only gotten like five
percent worse, but it was so borderline to
begin with that now it's very clearly over
the line that that's sort of my sense of it.
And we've got some more.
Jordan Peterson stuff coming up to talk about
Rodney Rhoden, about me leaving the country.
And again.
Sort of a misunderstanding.
Rodney Rohde added, This is why sometimes
I'm like, I shouldn't even talk about certain
things because it will be so misunderstood,
Rodney said.
David, my wife and I are proud to be members
who joined without accepting a discount so
we could further your broadcast experience.
Thank you, Rodney.
I appreciate that.
We enjoy your program very much and rarely
miss a show.
You've talked about how it's necessary to
take these crazy right wingers, such as Matt
Gates and Newt Gingrich.
Seriously, there are probably a few who do
not, but I think most of your listeners recognize
the seriousness of what these people are saying
and what they will do if they get the opportunity.
What would you have us do now that, you know,
we are taking them seriously?
We would not vote for them ever.
What else can we do?
We are ready.
So if things become bad in this country, you're
going to leave.
Or perhaps I should say, if things get worse.
Most of us do not have the means to just leave,
even if we wanted to do so.
It's a little disheartening to realize that
is your intention.
It's like that old expression when the going
gets tough, the tough get going out of the
country.
It's kind of like abandoning your teammates,
in my view.
Until then, keep up the good work.
Let let me say again.
I have no plan to leave the country.
I would love to spend more time in the place.
I was born Argentina and maybe after the pandemic
it'll be a possibility.
But I have no plan to leave my immediate family
is in the United States.
My work is in the United States.
Most everybody I know is in the United States.
I have no plan to leave.
The question was if it got so bad, you felt
you had to leave.
Where would you go?
And I listed the places.
That's all.
I'm not abandoning everybody.
I have no plan to leave, and I shouldn't even
have have brought it up.
OK?
Next email Mike says.
Just admit that you're a Democrat already.
You claiming that you're not a Democrat is
the equivalent of Tim Poole claiming he isn't
a Republican?
I don't know anything about Tim Poole's party
registration.
I just don't.
So I can't talk about Tim Poole when I claim
I'm not a Democrat.
I'm just telling you the truth.
I've never been a Democrat.
I don't care about the Democratic Party as
an institution.
I believe, as I said ten minutes ago in this
segment, that the Democratic Party's main
goal is its own self-preservation, not the
good of the average person.
So I would be lying if I said I was a Democrat
now, mostly in the modern era.
In Partizan elections, I'm opting to vote
for the Democrat, but I don't do anything
with the Democratic Party.
I don't donate to it.
I don't fundraise.
I don't care about it.
So when I say I'm not a Democrat, I'm just
telling you the truth.
All right, here's the last one, and this one
is as crazy as anything I have ever received,
J.J. wrote to me.
Did you know Biden made sure the hospital
stay bankrupted by making it so the water
runs on electricity?
That makes it so water for hospitals no longer
free.
The same with the paper towel dispensers,
almost everything got hooked up to electricity.
There are zero hospitals in America.
I didn't know that the doctor no longer check
the suction cup.
Part of the vagina.
So females might die from a tampon being stuck
in their bodies.
You know, I have to say the other day, I wrote.
I drove by some places where there used to
be hospitals.
All I saw was suction cups.
The hospitals are gone, so maybe JJ is on
to something.
Now, in all seriousness, this is this is scary.
This is scary.
Wacky.
I don't know what J.J. is talking about.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com.
You'll get instant access.
And remember, you can send me your thoughts
that may be featured in the mailbag info at
David Pakman dot com.
We'll see you on the bonus show or otherwise
Monday.